good afternoon everyone my name is dr
miller
and the scp we're going to be looking at
today
is scp-3935
containment class euclid disruption
class
kennek and risk class
caution special containment procedures
the town of salvation indiana has been
evacuated
and a fenced two kilometer quarantine
zone has been established around the
center of the town
roads leading to the nearby town of
eminence have been removed
and rerouted foundation personnel are to
monitor all known travel routes into
salvation
for signs of civilians any civilians
caught attempting to enter salvation
are to be remanded to the custody of
local authorities
cover story 39 35 18 hazardous waste
disaster
is currently being disseminated the
building containing scp-3935
salvation high school is to be guarded
by foundation security personnel
under no circumstances are any
non-authorized personnel to enter
scp-3935
individuals believed to be affected in
any way by scp-3935
are to be moved to temporary site 81.5
near eminence for evaluation
it is currently believed that the
original inhabitants of salvation are
unable to reproduce
deviation from this expectation is to be
closely monitored
exploration into scp-3935 is currently
forbidden
due to the hazardous conditions within
scp-3935
any future exploration attempts are
restricted to d-class personnel
only description
scp-3935 is an extra temporal
extra-spatial non-euclidean space
located beneath the salvation high
school
in salvation indiana while scp-3935 is
the designation for the specific anomaly
mentioned above
it is believed that the anomaly
currently affects the entire town of
salvation
as individuals have reported anomalous
events taking place
outside of scp-3935 as well the full
extent of these effects is not known
scp-3935 is reachable only through a
collapsed
section of sub-basement beneath the
salvation high school
near the northwest corner of the
building below the school's pool
it is believed that scp-3935 was the
source of anomalous activity that
took place in salvation high school in
the mid-1970s
which was investigated and contained by
members of the federal bureau of
investigation
unusual incidence unit information
pertaining to their investigation is
available elsewhere in this
the access point to scp-3935 proper
exists roughly 25 meters below the
collapsed section of basement
in a small anti-chamber containing a
stone arch
the original crater of the arch or how
it became buried so far underground in
the first place
are subjects of investigation inscribed
on the arch is a phrase in
english not believed to exist elsewhere
in literature
the way below wins deeper longer
unspeakable its patterns laid
the lost forever damned to wonder this
thing
a quiet madness made addendum
3935 1 discovery
scp-3935 was originally discovered
following a series of paranormal events
that took place within the salvation
high school
during the week of june 18th 1976
see addendum 3935 ii sometime after the
end of the primary anomalous activity
period at the school
the collapsed section of the wall and
floor leading to a narrow gap in the
foundation
was discovered by a member of the
custodial staff the collapsed wall which
is located in an unspecified basement
room below the primary basement
deteriorated even further until the gap
in the foundation was large enough that
a person could fit into
during an audit of the damage by a
contractor a member of the independent
team
accidentally slipped and fell into the
antechamber
near scp-3935 without a way to easily
extract the individual their supervisor
encouraged them to proceed into scp-3935
a short distance and see if there was a
way out when the individual did not
return from scp-3935
a search was conducted by members of the
contractor team
and local authorities when only two of
the 11 individuals who entered scp-3935
returned to the antechamber and when
they began to give accounts of their
experiences within
foundation personnel embedded in local
authorities took over the investigation
over time anomalous activity began to
become more and more common
outside of the high school in salvation
after the events that took place in june
1976
the town was officially condemned and
the entire populace was relocated
addendum 3935 2
unusual incidents unit field report
note the following is a summary of the
field report filed by uiu
field agents lonnie carter patrick
wilson
and ella hughes federal bureau of
investigation
unusual incidence unit the following is
a comprehensive report
detailing paranormal activity that took
place in the town of salvation indiana
between june 18 and june 23rd
1976 agents carter wilson and hughes
dispatched to sight of reported activity
substantial paranormal activity
encountered
additional resources requested and
employed in cover-up of paranormal
activity
no reported involvement by scp
foundation
or its agents no reported involvement by
global occult coalition
or its agents no reported involvement by
other notable entities
or their agents after asserting the
scope of the reported paranormal
activity
dispatched agents applied doses of
chemical 110
to the entire populace of salvation all
inhabitants accounted for
and moved to processing center in
indianapolis
for further analysis quarantine
established around salvation
after extensive interviews of the
population of salvation
the following timeline of paranormal
activity has been constructed
from these eyewitnesses accounts sunday
night
10th grade students diane beasley and
cassandra thompson report hearing what
they described as
someone trying to speak under the ground
when passing by the high school on their
way home from a sunday night
church service ms thompson reports this
to her mother who
ignores it monday
during gym class 11th grade student
oliver baker
claims that he can hear voices coming
from underneath the pool
several other students corroborate his
story when school officials come to
investigate they do not discern anything
unusual
notably the lining at the bottom of the
pool appears cracked
several female students report seeing
faceless things
instead of their own reflections in the
mirror of a second story bathroom during
a passing period
they do not seem bothered by this during
lunch announcements many students
describe being able to hear a third
voice
speaking unintelligibly below the
broadcast
the pa room sits in a media center near
the pool less than 40 meters from the
entrance of the sub-basement room
and collapsed wall tuesday
students arriving to the school noticed
that the indiana state flag
is more than three meters above the top
of the flagpole
attached to nothing the american flag is
not found
when observed students claim that they
can also see
nine female figures hanging by ropes
from the flagpole
which disappear immediately after being
seen
during a freshman biology class one
student suddenly stands
is seen rolling their eyes back in their
head and descending
suddenly into the floor and out of sight
they reappear shortly after above a
ceiling panel in the corner of the room
despite being unable to identify the
student
several of his classmates insist it was
just a joke
several students described seeing a
student they did not recognize at the
school on tuesday
when pushed to give details of the
student's appearance
none are able to do so apparently the
only defining characteristic of this
student was a purple satchel
with the word syncope written on the
side in white embroidery
a custodian reports seeing something
standing at the bottom of the pool
staring at him wednesday
upon arriving at the school maintenance
staff and the custodians note that there
is a full
two inches of water across all levels of
the school
inexplicably the school's principal dr
ervin white
decides not to close the school at 7
56 a.m the entire school hears someone
whisper the word hello
in their right ear members of the school
band realize that their instruments no
longer produce
any sound however when played the
students report
seeing a small black human-shaped thing
flickering in and out of view
in the corner of the room facing the
wall
one student ava littaway witnesses a
dark figure walking
up and away from the school through the
air at an impossible angle
eventually the figure disappears from
sight and is never seen again
no other students address this thursday
during a gym class senior nate bennett
avoids a dodgeball when it phases
through him
as he begins to sink into the floor he
screams for help
nobody who noticed seemed motivated
enough to help him
the entire school shifts up roughly a
foot off its foundations at 11
23 am the vice principal sent to inspect
it describes
something small with too many faces
grinning adam from underneath the
building
before the school slowly resettles
the boys locker rooms disappear and are
replaced by
something that screamed witnesses are
unable to provide any further details
as the students leave the school for the
day they see nine young women hanging in
the air
tilted forward at a 45 degree angle
roughly 25 meters above the school's
parking lot
they can be seen silently mouthing words
all witnesses describe their appearance
as
ugly and unremarkable they vanish at
approximately 3 pm
the majority of all residents describe
hearing a child's voice say the word
hello below them at this time
a panic ensues as town officials have no
response for the women in the sky
the principal decides to close the
school on friday
friday the entire student body shows up
for school on friday being unable to get
into the school due to the doors being
locked
they assemble outside the front door and
wait no
individuals in this group could describe
why they were there
there is a knock on a window and the
entire student body sees a small
black humanoid form standing outside of
a second story classroom
the figure begins to phase in and out of
the window
the figure disappears and then begins to
phase in and out of other windows
witnesses describe its movements as
jerky
erratic and spasmodic the figure
disappears and the front door unlocks
itself
the student body enters the school the
interior of the school has become
non-euclidean
as the students approach the back of the
space they realize they are moving down
not into all students now hear whispers
and some at the edge of their group hear
drums in the distance
in the distance they see the archway
leading to scp-3930
suddenly the entire mass of students
shifts 50 meters outside of the space
and are suddenly encased in rock and
earth
the students spend roughly 20 seconds
trapped in this area
before reappearing back in the school
all students report being the only one
in the building
and after wandering through the hallways
for a short time
coming across a doorway below a doorway
and entering the small sub-basement room
inside
the students report seeing three
separate visions
a woman crouched over a body of water
blood surrounding her feet
and her arms extended into the water up
to her elbows
a farmhouse in the middle of a grove of
trees that is burning while nine
humanoid figures hang in the air
overhead and a weeping woman digging in
a field until her hands begin to rot
and fall apart once the visions subside
the small black humanoid appears
students hear the entities say the word
hello again
are immediately surrounded by nine
screaming female figures
and are then suddenly in their own homes
as additional agents begin to enter the
town to apply amnestics to the subjects
additional anomalous activity is
reported around the town
several individuals report seeing bodies
hanging in the sky
several individuals report turning on
their taps
and human hair and mucus flowing out
instead of water
several individuals report feeling as if
their facial features had disappeared
entirely
while several other reported seeing
faceless creatures in town
a completely still black humanoid entity
is seen
frantically appearing and reappearing in
rapid succession
up and down the main thoroughfare in the
town
one unidentified woman reports
witnessing a weeping young woman
running back into the school building
after following her into the now
unlocked
sub-basement she is unable to find the
young woman
but is the first to report the collapsed
floor
aftermath summary over the next few days
uiu amnestic regimens begin to take
effect
most townspeople are readily convinced
that the things they saw were
hallucinations
as a result of toxic gases blown south
from a factory to the north
at the end of the next week contractors
assessing the damage to the school
discover the sub-basement room as well
as the entrance to scp-3935
foundation involvement begins shortly
thereafter
addendum 3935-3
initial exploration and recovery log
note the following log is a
transcription of audio and video
recordings gathered from the initial
foundation search and rescue attempt
into scp-3935
begin log all right mike's hot
let's go agents ellis porter and haskell
enter scp-3935
each is equipped with a shoulder mounted
torch which illuminates upon entering
the space
beyond the archway all right so first
things first
there's definitely something happening
back here
the walls are getting pretty tight stay
close
team proceeds forward can you feel that
what the air feels funny
[Applause]
shoulder-mounted torch illuminates the
wall next to agent haskell
images are carved into the rock similar
to a child's drawings
come on i think i feel a breeze might be
an opening up here
team continues to push through the rock
tunnel
[Applause]
agent porter's camera suddenly goes
black a moment later it appears to be
looking up at two sources of light
likely ellis and haskell's torches as
agent porter falls
what the [ __ ] just happened porter
porter where i can't turn around where
is he
i hear
both agents struggle to continue forward
the tight space continuing to impede
their movement
after a short time of struggling both
men fall forward
into a larger open space jesus christ
[Applause]
he's not behind me can you see him in
there
[Music]
we okay we need to get another team down
here
he might have fallen in a review or
something or slipped back there or
tell us look both men turn around and
illuminate the space they are in with
their shoulder shoulder-mounted torches
in front of them is a massive structure
seemingly carved out of the stone around
them
a thick fog covers the entire chamber
beyond the fog dim lights are visible in
openings in the structure
it is impossible to determine how high
or low the structure extends
the structure is only reachable via a
narrow stone bridge that extends across
a large
chasm between the agents and the far
wall
is this the high school why does it look
like that
yeah the geology isn't right but
yeah look there that's the main entrance
there's another door there yeah
this is the school
[Applause]
there's another one below it and one
below that
how far down does this go are there any
other
both men pause appearing over the bridge
in front of them are nine
female humanoid figures their face is
obscured by
long white hair they do not move
hang on the nine entities hang in the
air for a short time
before suddenly appearing 10 meters
backwards and then another 10
and then right in front of the door to
the subterranean school structure
the faces of all nine suddenly become
visible and although they are not
visible to the recording due to the
distance
both agents noticeably recoil afterwards
all the entities disappear jesus christ
jesus christ holy [ __ ] what was that
all right oh god we're not
ready for this there is a sudden sound
of many voices speaking in hushed tones
in the distance
both agents react to the sound
survivors come on let's go
both agents cross the chasm bridge
leading towards the non-euclidean
replica of salvation high school upon
entering they find the main concourse of
the school
no other entities are visible within
porter
anyone is anyone here
jesus you feel this too like you're
looking at the whole room all at once
yeah it's the [ __ ] the walls don't
make any sense
come on my air voice is down this way
let's go
both men move quickly down the closest
hallway as they do
doors on either side of the wall are
visible
although neither agent seems to notice
faces are occasionally visible through
glass panes in the doorways
they are impossible to make out here
this is the door to the auditorium i'll
bet they're in
agent ellis opens the door as he does
his video recorder disconnects
agent haskell screams and scrambles
backwards
the voices increase dramatically in
volume and from agent haskell's
perspective
on the ground near the door nine female
figures appear around agent alice
their movements are erratic and their
bodies are contorted into impossible
positions
they close on agent ellis and the man
and the figures
disappear [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] ellis
god [ __ ] agent haskell stands and begins
to run away from the door
as he reaches the end of the hall he
looks back over his shoulder
and sees nine figures approaching oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh no hello is anyone there help me
god please help me hello
[ __ ] me please god help agent haskell
turns again to see the nine figures in
the hallway behind him
though they are no longer moving forward
instead
they hang in the air aren't moving as
agent haskell's pace slows
he watches them for a moment and then
stops
his breathing becomes quick
what what do you want
agent haskell turned slowly to look
behind him
and upon turning his face to face with a
small black humanoid creature
sitting upside down on the ceiling of
the hallway
the creature has no discernable features
but its presence creates
significant visual distortion in agent
haskell's camera
[Applause]
there is a loud low sound like a bell
tolling
the sound continues for 20 seconds
the video feed for agent haskell goes
dead
the audio feed begins to experience
severe distortion
as if the signal was being drawn out
over a longer period of time
there is a snapping noise and then the
feed goes silent
all three signals are quiet for some
time eventually
all three radios begin responding again
just wants to be would you like to just
be
[Applause]
yeah yeah we all would die we all would
die
no more of the night
we all would
they're back they're back
silence for 81 minutes just like every
other wall
this hall is like every other home
[Applause]
silence for 18 minutes ellis
god can anyone hear me
does anyone know who i am
i can't see the light anymore i can't
see
oh god it's only dark it's only dark
down here
i just want to see the lighting silence
for nine minutes
[Applause]
his madness will
[Applause]
[Applause]
silence for nine minutes
silence for nine minutes i see you down
there
you want me to come in do you want me to
you want us all to come down be with you
down
[Music]
[Applause]
silence for nine minutes fall forever
fall forever fall forever
fall forever fall forever
silence for nine minutes goes on forever
it goes down forever we're in here
forever
this war in the night and know the
salvation
down forever and ever none of them got
out
none of them got out none of them got
got out out out
no more transmissions from any of the
three microphones received
after this point possible exploration
attempts into scp-3935
using class d subjects are forthcoming
end log
addendum 3935 iv
anomalous activity in salvation
the following are incidents of anomalous
activity in salvation indiana
reported by staff during the
foundation's occupancy
of the town reports of a figure
dressed as a uiu agent who tries to
direct
individuals towards the high school this
figure disappears if
observed for too long agent willis
reported seeing a small black
figure sitting underneath his vehicle
upon approaching after looking beneath
the vehicle the figure was not there
afterwards agent willis reports always
seeing the black figure in his
peripheral vision
many reports of sounds coming from a
grove of trees near the high school
examination of the grove returned only a
dilapidated one-bedroom house
and nine in the backyard the appearance
of nine hanging female figures drives
off the exploration team
further examination of the grove was
unable to locate the house
after dark many agents report seeing the
nine female humanoid entities
jerkily moving towards them in the dark
only to slide into the earth or
fade away before reaching them several
reports of similar figures
up in trees reports of several bodies
no more than nine at a time that float
up from the bottom of a small pond
outside of town
and rest at the surface of the water
before sinking and
disappearing likely connected in some
way to the night
that appeared behind the house in the
grove
addendum 3935 5
interview with person of interest note
the following interview was conducted by
agent ryan ames
in 2002 the subject mrs valerie fletcher
was a teacher at salvation high school
during the period of anomalous activity
in 1976
can you tell me about your time at
salvation
oh well you know i
already told you about the memory loss
i just can't seem to string anything
together anymore
i was a teacher though see i taught
hey english i believe
yes i was at salvation for some time
what can you tell me about the town
anything you remember that stands out
well it was quiet you know
one road in one road out we didn't get
many outsiders so we were pretty
tight-knit community
i don't even think we had police you
know because
who wouldn't think that we didn't have
crime
not really
there were always some people who would
tell stories you know
like yes
hello hello you were just talking about
people telling stories
mrs fletcher oh the young people would
go out into the woods and get themselves
all
riled up about whatever spook or spectre
they thought they were seeing out there
[Applause]
there were some things that were strange
well like i don't know if they were
actually strange or if it's just my
memory giving me trouble again
like sometimes you'd be driving down the
street
and you'd see someone standing on the
side of the road
waving just like this and
you look back and nobody would be there
i think it was just the kids playing
pranks on people
what about at the high school anything
strange ever happened there
high school where you were a teacher
salvation high school i
yes i was a teacher i taught english
i think do you remember anything strange
happening at the school
no i mean nothing out of the ordinary we
did have a child
disappearance once i think
she was seen by the pool
and then no one ever saw them again
i just think
well i i think they ended up saying
they just ran away some of them were
problem children you know
and there's just nothing you can do
maybe it was better for them
i don't know there were a lot of people
in salvation who had some strong
opinions
and some of them didn't sit very well
with the young people
what do you mean oh you know
the church was very important in town we
had a few and almost everyone went
but we had if i remember this right
there was one girl who got pregnant
i think and
i'm sorry what would be talking about
i can't like i can't seem to
hello a girl who got pregnant
yes out of wedlock it was quite the
scandal
i don't remember what happened to her
but i know a lot of people were upset
about it
you know i i don't remember that girl's
name
no no but i do remember her coming back
to me one time
and asking about something strange she
had heard
she was pregnant out of wedlock
it was quite a scandal and didn't want
to
well didn't want the boys to see
but she said she was sitting on the
bleachers
and kept hearing a knocking
like someone hitting hitting something
she didn't want the boys
didn't want them to mrs fletcher i'm
sorry
i'm just so all over anymore
she uh she said she would see things
sometimes too
but i don't know anything about that she
she also well
i don't know if i dreamed this or not
but i remember her saying hello to me
too many times all at once too not
like a greeting it was the only word she
knew for
for a moment like she like it was all
she hello
is there anything else about salvation
you remember
i it all blurs
together after all this time i
seem to remember there was one time one
time when
well somebody found a girl
maybe maybe the same but i don't know
well i don't know but they were strung
up
in the woods like a hanging
i think i think they called it a suicide
one of the girls who did cheer
you know but uh it was someone who
well i don't know why they do anything
like that
they had a note they had written with
uh i'm sorry
anyway a note in their hand
actually asked me to look at it
see if it was the same handwriting and
everything
what did it say oh well
if i remember right it was on one side
they just had a
just like a drawing like a building but
strange somehow i don't remember why
on the other it was just a word written
over and over again
i don't remember what it was i think it
was wet
or something you you couldn't make it
out
very queer now that i think think of it
what a strange thing to write just
before you die
don't you think do you remember anything
from the week you were evacuated
no no well
i mean the vapors were very strong that
week from the factory
they said you might experience
hallucinations
and i definitely did i see i saw
i i mean i saw something
i saw well
there was one day i imagined a child
floating backwards into a wall and then
well they suffocated
heard him screaming and pounding against
the wall
we all did it was
it was a strange hallucination
he stopped
i'm i'm sorry what am i doing here again
we're just talking mrs fletcher i'm here
with the insurance company we were
talking about the hallucination
remember about the boy in the war
oh yes i'm sorry i just don't
remember quite so well anymore
the hallucination though i saw that boy
go in
and then we didn't hear anything else
now that i think about it
that's very peculiar
the hallucination was very clear he just
he cried for a long time and
seemed so afraid but
well i don't
i don't seem to remember it bothering me
i i think it must have been
a prank one last question mrs fletcher
after the earthquake they found a room
underneath the basement near the pool
do you know anything about that
no i i don't
nobody ever went into the room but the
janitors
i think just storage
though you know i think that girl
asked about that room what
said she well she heard
some things coming from it she was very
interested in it i think before she uh
well
either way i i don't i don't know
i might not be remembering that right i
do
well some of the hallucinations
you know they told us not to think about
them anymore
so i try not to but
i know some other people who have and
they
they aren't doing very well anymore
thank you for your time mrs fletcher
actually before i go do you think you
know anything about this
well yes
i do those are the
that's the cheerleaders
there were well let me think
there were 10 of them though i think
unless something happened to one of them
there were definitely 10.
this concludes today's lecture thank you
all for listening
if indeed you still are and you were all
dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
cesar hintern zarguran
arbiter sewell the morrigan
brent langrier revenant
brian sanchez patrick bailey
matthew gilmore eric corbich
kawaii fire keeper joker corvus
carcast if aqua king madding
james saba and nj vojak if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos
and some other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash the vulcan thank you
you